is controversial if you think about it
but it's the healthiest relationships
are from the BDSM
community and I will explain why
I'm healthy no no I need you to like if
someone claim this the reason why I say
it's healthy is in order to be
able to be in that type of relationship
because it is so extreme to the point
where sometimes there is a chance of
death yeah because people engage in such
extreme activities you need extreme
trust in order to get into it is there
is there any data that backs this up so
the the idea no this just sounds like
this sounds crazy so I I know I'm I'm
going to give you the example okay
because things are so extreme you're not
just going to do it even though it's a
fantasy you're not going to do it unless
you trust that person it's not going to
actually kill you does that make sense